here's a story you can tell with a sheet
of paper it begins like all good
tragedies with a hamburger fold next the
corners by the crease are folded to meet
in the middle forming a point and then
finally the two flaps opposite that
point are folded up to make the brim of
a paper hat but my sheet of paper is too
small to make a hat that will fit on my
head but that's okay because we're not
actually folding a paper hat we are
folding ourselves a boat to tell the
story of a sailor lost at sea ooh a
storm approached and the waves became
rough tossing the ship into a cliff the
entire front of the boat was ripped
clean off then lightning struck from
above splinters and fire erupted as the
top of the ship was lost next another
Collision right into a cliff or an
iceberg or something the back of the
ship was gone the ship was never found
search and rescue were undertaken but
all they ever managed to find was the
sailor's
t-shirt